laissez vous embarquer dans une
expérience surprenante en février
prochain le jazzman geoffrey seco
proposera une musique atmosphérique un
concert sous hypnose seconde après
seconde et respiration après respiration
vous allez vous approchez d'un désir
d'un rêve
c'est vraiment un voyage permettant à
chaque personne de retrouver s'il le
veut s'il veut juste écouter il ne fait
qu'écouter je voyais des gens qui
étaient partis comme les demandes en une
dans une méditation on retrouve son
animal totem et c'est assez c'est le
truc complètement planant et cool c'est
vraiment très sympa
préparez aussi vos valises au théâtre
espace coluche de plaisir on vous emmène
en voyage de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique avec ada havas l'histoire
deux soeurs jumelles séparées par la vie
ou en espagne grâce au flamenco dan
plata
touré
quand on prend
beaucoup de théâtre des classiques
proposés et six dates réservées aux
jeunes publics
la saison du tech démarre en septembre
avec mordant et incisive de caisse par
trop lourd tout court mais je trouve que
vraiment ballon alors on dit toujours
par les temps qui courent il faut rire
mais c'est vrai on a besoin de rire mais
quel que soit le temps qui courent
d'ailleurs le temps passe et on a besoin
de rire et de s'amuser et de se détendre
puis mitterrand à l'époque il
s'allierait pas avec les écologistes
couler leurs bateaux dans les ports dans
le pacifique du voyage du rire de
l'émotion le théâtre espace coluche a
programmé une trentaine de rendez-vous